[Musique]
bonjour thierry renard bonjour nourrit
viol tombe on joue à la martinique
vous êtes l'un des porte paroles de jean
luc mélenchon le candidat de la france a
soumises pour le premier tour c'est un
exercice délicat tir renard parce que au
moment où nous sommes à l'antenne jean
luc mélenchon est sur le point de
s'exprimer via sa chaîne youtube sur les
résultats d'une consultation lancée
auprès des partisans de la france est
soumise quant à la marche à suivre au
second tour avez vous été surpris jean
du coup la tire renard avez vous été
surpris par cette salve de critiques à
l'égard de jean luc mélenchon sur son
silence ce soir du premier tour
pas du tout je n'ai pas été surpris
parce que tout le monde voulait que
simplement jean luc mélenchon se met
adoubé emmanuel macron encausse et le
programmes des manuels mâcon nous
l'avons combattu tout comme nous avons
combattu le programme de marine le pen
mais ce front républicain ce fameux
front républicaine temps est vrai dans
la vie il faut faire des choix
là au second tour ce que l'on propose
aux français souhaitaient les français
ont choisi de se proposer eux-mêmes ou
second tour c'est une ségrégationniste
raciale en face un soldat sioniste
financier entre deux cycles de la
sioniste
chacun va choisir celui qui voudra ou va
choisir de ne pas voter ou de voter
blanc
mais c'est extrêmement compliqué parce
que nous savons que les deux choix ne
sont pas bons certains voient jean luc
mélenchon comme un aigri frustré peu
déçu ils le voient petit joueur
écoutez le vote
c'est quelque chose de secret donc
normalement on n'a pas à diop ou qui on
va voter sauf si on veut influencer et
parce qu on a des convictions et on sait
que ce qu'on dit va permettre les choses
avancent et aujourd'hui jean-luc
mélenchon a choisi pour l'instant de ne
pas s'exprimer à titre personnel qui
consulte sa base il consulte sa base
normalement c'est jusqu'au
mais que l'on peut voter donc moi même
j'ai été amené à voter sur le site sur
lequel je rappelle quand même qu'il n'ya
que trois options
l'abstention le vote blanc nul houleux
votre mac ont l'option du vote le pen
n'est pas une option pour nous là nous
sommes très clairs sur ce sujet même
dans les consultations faites par les
militants le vote le pen n'est pas une
option
donc pour vous jean luc mélenchon
demeure cohérent malgré la meute qui lui
crachent dessus
oui mais vous savez c'est pas parce que
tout le monde vous dit que vous avez
tant que vous avez réellement temps oui
ce positionnement de jean luc mélenchon
est ce pour mieux préparer la suite
devenir ou être la première formation de
gauche et et pourquoi pas d'opposer
d'opposition face à l'un ou l'autre
là vous êtes d'un des calculs politiques
c'est méconnaître c'est méconnaître la
france insoumise
jean luc mélenchon il est globalement en
france ce que moi je suis ici c'est à
dire un insoumis à qui on a demandé de
porter les valeurs parce que il était
peut-être le mieux à même le plus près
pour pouvoir porter ces valeurs là donc
c'est une idée que nous défendons donc
si lui qui portent l'idée mais l'idée ne
vient pas de lui
l'idée vient de la base ce sont 450
mille personnes qui ont soutenu sa
candidature
ce sont 450 mille personnes qui donnent
leurs idées qui donnent leur avis quand
même journée la retransmettre cet avis
jean luc mélenchon avait quand même
c'était pas secret il avait quand même
envie de dépasser très largement le
candidat socialiste ce qu'il a fait il
aurait même pu dépasser françois fillon
ce qui l'a pas faire quelque chose près
mais aujourd'hui il est il le mieux le
mieux placé pour représenter la
véritable dois chan france est notre cas
si ce qui se dit c'est ce que disent les
chiffres encore vous restez dans un
débat d'hommes
la france est soumise à un but faire
changer les choses passées à la 6ème
république
l'urgence sociale c'est à dire rendre
l'argent au peuple et faire que les gens
soient heureux sortir de la finance
c'est ça qui est important pour nous
l'écologie aussi c'est important pour
nous faire en sorte que nous laissions
la planète mieux que nous l'ayons
trouver si on peut au moins vivable pour
nos enfants
si ça qui est important sympa pour cette
fois ci alors non pas la tête à l'école
va préparer le coup d'après aujourd'hui
dire aujourd'hui nous avons fait ce que
nous avons fait aux élections
présidentielles qui est un score très
honorable mais que romain ans qu'on nous
nous remarquons que la jeunesse
hexagonal est déjà dans la rue elle
critique elle ne veut pas de ce second
tour
notre avenir c'est la jeunesse parce que
des vieux gorille comme moi comme on dit
ils seront plus là dans quelques années
ce sont les jeunes qui vont reprendre le
flambeau et c'est vers eux qu'on doit
regarder aujourd'hui personne ne parle
de ces jeunes qui sont dans la rue et
qui ne veulent ni de télévisions ont
montré les images mais ce n'est pas une
manifestation un peu tardive réputé pu
le faire avant histoire de lettre
peut-être la pression sur tout le monde
mais ils avaient l'espoir mais
maintenant qu'ils avaient un peu
d'espoir maintenant ils sont
complètement désespéré alors est ce que
jean luc mélenchon alors que devenir cet
espoir pour cette jeunesse et comment
premièrement il ya une chose qu'il faut
savoir c'est que quel que soit le
président de la république qui va sortir
des urnes toujours dans la vème
république il y avait ce qu'on appelait
l'état de grâce est le fait que après
l'élection présidentielle
il y avait une certaine majorité qui se
dégage est naturellement dans les
élections législatives ouais
aujourd'hui on en est sûr ça n'existera
pas l'état de grâce déjà on n'a jamais
vu des gens manifester entre deux tours
d'une élection
ça veut dire qu'il ya quelque chose de
grave qui se passe les gens se sont
frustrés parce que leur a vendu un
paquet qui était peut-être bien enrobés
mais qui avait rien dedans ou ce qu'il y
avait dedans c'est très mauvais pour eux
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
ségrégationniste financiers s'il avoue
pouvoir ça va être du haut pour le
peuple
je ne parle même pas du fait de main il
n'a pas ça va être dur pour le peuple
donc dans tous les cas de figure ça va
être dur pour le peuple
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre ici ça
que les gens sont en train de voir
maintenant et c'est pour ça que vous
avez tous à deux personnes qui se
demandent même à quoi va servir ce
second tour parce qu'ils savent que ça
va être mauvais pour redouter une forte
abstention
en général ça on vote beaucoup plus au
deuxième tour qu'au premier tour elle
avoue phénomène inverse
c'est pas moi qui aurais doute ce sont
les candidats du second tour qui redoute
cette forte abstention
parce que lorsqu'on est candidat à une
élection présidentielle au second tour
celui qui est élu est le candidat de
tous les français
une chose va être certaine c'est que
celui qui sera élu au soir du 7 mai sera
une candidat e
le président d'une partie minoritaire de
la france alors il faut préparer ce
coude après les législatives de juin
2010 est la france est soumise par
exemple en martinique est ce que vous
avez l'intention d'y aller
il s'agira de donner une sorte de de
contre-pouvoir il faudrait sano
contre-pouvoir selon vous contre ce
président qui sera élu au soir du 7 mai
à lomé premièrement les élections
législatives
c'est simplement dans maintenant là
l'esprit de la vème république avec le
quinquennat si simplement devenu le 3e
et le 4e tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'est à dire on va élire
les députés qui normalement c'est eux
qui vont gérer la france puisque
il est de coutume que le président de la
république choisissent le premier
ministre dans la plus grande formation
qui se trouve à l'assemblée nationale
donc là il faut y aller il faut deux
chambres mais c'est la continuité c'est
une élection nationale
la france est soumise va sûrement
représenter va présenter des candidats
je vous rappelle quand même qu'on a fait
quand même près de trente mille voix en
martinique 27 et demi pour cent
quasiment ce n'est pas négligeable nous
donc vous irez la france est soumise va
présenter des candidats qui nul ne le
sait encore ce n'est quand même pas
encore le moment d'en parler puisqu'il
ya l'élection présidentielle chaque
chose en son temps
mais il faut savoir que de toutes les
façons ces candidats là ce n'est pas un
nom qui compte puisque nous notre
programme il est clair et il change pas
c'est toujours l'avenir en commun si ce
que nous allons défendre sur les bancs
de l'assemblée nationale
merci d'avancé ce matin avec naughty
gijón à rappelle que vous êtes le des
porte paroles de jean luc mélenchon la
france et son musicien article merci
d'être venu avec nous dans son crédit
bonne journée merci
[Musique]